今日肇社長ですというわけでお待たせいたしました
肇社長の動画魔改造コーナー発表会位
たくさんのご応募本当にありがとうございました応募件数がですね
いや県は声絶対ぐらいで本当にすごい尾瀬の方が僕の書道と吸収していただいて本当に
ありがとうございます結構楽しみだしあの
結構厳しめに行きますよ動画編集というのはね面白くてナンボですからね
厳しくいきますが厳しく受けで見ていきましょうおっぱいではさっそく見ていき
ましょう
何がこちらですね
[音楽]
[笑い]
ん
何なるほど
あれほど寝過ぎ事務所こちらです
おおおおすごいてゲスト
を
[音楽]
九州次いきます
堀厩舎感じる横する方法
凄い凄い編集がしっかりしている
ああああああああ
ua
[拍手]
もうすごい
おおすごいすごいすごい卒業おりにつけるって作戦ですねありがとうございますさあ次
は困るよ
あっすわー不意打ちだった今なぁあろうとそうそういうのもすごいをすると思います
正義さんが誤ってくださいこもった次です
見ていきましょう
oos a big 車顔亡くなったことを守ったりまん
うわぁ凄い
をえっ
[拍手]
[笑い]
すごい
何が起きてるんだこれ
うわぁわぁわあ
ん
よくやったねこんなのや2号あんな僕のここで切るねで使うっていう発想ですねこれは
すごいなあ
彼もよくた次です
おやべスながらっぽい
[拍手]
バッハ
p 中になんてことーくよああ
えっ
すごいなんでこういう行間すごいぞ
[音楽]
ウォーターっ
バッハ
すごいなぁそういう使い方か
偶像ではみたいになってましたねやず面白いますのはやっぱりすごいでもも沿いとって
ね動画で変だとを使うんですよ俺の体しか使ってないから2万とか
cibone ストーンの見ていきましょうかっこいいよ
大
4日
4を
[笑い]
[音楽]
どうどういうコンセプトないああすごい
バッハ
あっはず動画お皿
わけわかんないできる
ねええええ
俺が反応にあげてるんだね終わった後はいミラーかなぁ
[音楽]
あっはうげーーーーー
始めた
[音楽]
ウバでねー
a
[音楽]
レイズゲー
おっ
a
あっえっ
そのし今は叶う
or すげー
[拍手]
ああああああああ
[笑い]
めっちゃすげー
うわぁすげぇとちゃんとフェイク省の広告マンのせてくれるレスえええええええ
クリしたあーこんなレベルになるんですねびっくりしちゃったありがとうございます
知らない人がいっぱいてる人たちみんなが作ってくれたんですかねさぁ次です次行き
ましょうよ
[音楽]
ああああああん
ああああ工具っぽくしたらね広告じゃないよねびっくり souma
よもう
おおーー
[音楽]
えっぱ崩して祀ったと思うよ
フォースいい
はたちの顔がん
[音楽]
1の様子がこちらね
1ですアナは約7年間の捜索活動おっ
女の代表作としては
[音楽]
レンジレンジやトマトマト
母
じゃあ出場歌手の発表ではあなたの美術展
じゃあ家へ行った改正はっはっぴょーようこそですか
prep the live いやすごい
すげー何がすごいかわかんないけどすげーよ
を学校じゃんもう前これ
始めんの
組体操 no て本すごいな大丈夫がこれ学校でを
フォア
[拍手]
[音楽]
なるほどねー
あっすげー
方
[音楽]
おおすごいいっ
たすげー好きですけええ
ああ
[音楽]
バーっ4 a
なにこれパソコン
すげー
ふおお
もうえええ何これやわー
[音楽]
[拍手]
呼ぶ切り抜いたねー
[音楽]
ねっと
復興祭行きましょう次です
もう
はい
[音楽]
起用がでかいなぁ
そこは突っ込まんだけど靴威力てよだれ図案ですよね集中するとかもよ
ん
あのああ
[音楽]
ええええええマニーはの
う
何なにぬ
a
ええええええやファー帆の形ってすごすぎてびっくりしたんですけどあのトンネル僕今
回転させてましたからねぇ
いやまぁよ王様は何所
[笑い]
すげー
俺だ
貴様待って
[拍手]
破ってこいで a
[音楽]
合う e 2セルの上
ああ
何コレスうううううっ
[音楽]
もう
ああああああ
はっはー
ではすごいすごいすごいすごいすごいポケモンですよこれ
4待て0と先制打
これすごいぞ多分
[拍手]
ホットポッポッポッ奪っ長谷川すぎでおかあちゃんはもう
米ドゼーずありがとうございますよ
[音楽]
a てもいいん
[拍手]
バッハ
宇治ゲー
[音楽]
次次次次すげーエンディングにめっちゃってましたね今感動しちゃうすごいよ
んです映画ワールドオブソックス予告編だって
過ぎなかっつ後ソ
これは彼が全然に放った言葉である
[音楽]
何
米は元年の日本
紙面始めた超
[音楽]
何何すごい
あ
何もなかったと思うよ
を
はっはっは
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
夕方になった
すんぜええ
無駄にかっこいいなぁまずですごい怖いやなにこれ
みんなに穴開けてインナー靴下に
おおすごい
このフリー素材ですねイラストやあれじゃないですねサー俺飛んでたなぁと思うよ
[音楽]
バッハ
僕すげー
付与なんかニコニコにあるマット動画みたい
[音楽]
うばがへ
なんだよ
よ僕ねー
うえっ
いや都合1な倉庫内素材でよくここまで出来ましたねー
ながー
すごいよもうなんでもありだよ
ああああああ
[音楽]
mr あんの
座って待って遠くないん
またその20秒間だけど
ギターやっハギター弾きださずん
おっ
うーんん j ありがとうよっすごいすごいすごいそれがニコ二コ動形にあるちゃんと
してマットどうかって感じでしたね次行きましょうよ
どうする
戦う
[音楽]
あ右が折れたのねー
青子世たああ
大
[音楽]
持っ
はぁ
なんだこれよあああっっっ
もうせやすいあえずーまたぷっ
パブーはぁ
パブー
放った
パパたーーー
パパはぁ
ああすごいなんか不思議な8ビット館
ファミコンかになりますね4
ただ歪んでるなぁ
[音楽]
なにこれすごい
方は強い
[音楽]
またば者
やろーって思うよ
はあああああ
バッハ
[音楽]
[拍手]
あーあやめ
薄毛よ
あーあいやーすごいすごいすごい
女もん全部靴下ないといけてなかったけどちゃんと曲になってましたに成り立ってまし
たねすごいすごいはいというわけで本当にたくさんのご応募ありがとうございました
あの動画をこんなことに使うのたっていうがいろんなダメさせていただいてすごく勉強
になったことがありました
なんか本土今ご覧になった道
意外に本当にたくさん良い作品があったので本当に思ってくださった皆様ありがとう
ございましたまた機会方はぜひやろうと思いますもうなんか本当にいろんな言ったら
弊社いると自分までねぇ加工学べることがあるんだよても良い機会になったなと思い
ました
じゃあな
[音楽]
[拍手]
ああああああああ